- The 90's were the best time of all time,
and the toys rocked, and life was great.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Oh! Hit Clips!
- It's like 60 seconds of one
song, it's not even a song.
- What?
- The only part I remember of that song
is that 60 seconds of it.
- If Hit Me Baby One More Time
isn't on this, I'm walking.
- Why did children want
things with one earphone?
Like, you can't shut your
parents out with one earphone.
- This feels like something
that Xenon would have,
because it's like kind of futuristic
but also extremely shitty.
- Is there volume? Can
you adjust the volume?
- It's perfect the way it is.
- It's amazing where we've
gone in the past 10 years,
where like this amount of storage can now,
this is like everything,
where as back then,
it was the equivalent to
one Oops, I Did It Again.
- Not even!
- [Voiceover] Tamagotchi's!
- This was a good idea until you realized
that it could die, and
you had to care for it.
- I'd feed it in the
morning, go to school.
I'd race home, and rush to
it and try to save its life
before it died, and it
always died in my arms.
- This one's already pooped.
He's already gone to the corner.
- We have to clean it.
- Oh my god, there's three buttons.
How come I don't know how to use this?
- Push the middle button.
- Woah!
- Oh no.
- I don't know what's happening.
There's bunch of hearts on the screen.
- (laughing) It's just hearts.
- I think that's good.
- Tamagotchi just kinda
moves left and right
with his mouth randomly opening.
- This is a Skip It,
but it's not a Skip It.
It's just like, the Walmart Skip It.
- My favorite ones were
the ones that, like,
they had a counter on it.
- What do I do?
- How do you get it going?
- There you go.
Ow! F***!
- Go!
Keep swinging!
(laughing) There you go!
- [Woman in Jacket] This is so
much harder than I remember.
- I'm not saying I'm
gonna be great at this,
but I will be great at this.
- Okay let's see it.
- Okay.
- Woah!
- Yeah, Keith! Yeah, Keith!
There you go!
- (laughing) How did you do it?
Alright, here we go.
Skip It. Skip It.
- See if you can skip up to the top.
- Were 90's kids just
in really good shape?
- Gak!
What does it say? Smelly Gak?
Oh come on!
- You could order this right out of
Nickelodeon Magazine, please!
- What is that smell?
It's the worst smell!
- Isn't it crazy that
kids, there's a demand for
kids to have, like, awful smelling toys?
- It's feels sweaty.
- Who can make a (beep) the fastest?
- Grow up.
- I'm faking like I have a booger.
- Ew.
- Look at it go!
- You guys, this is amazing!
Does NASA know about this?
- Bop It.
First Generation Bop It, because Bop It
got way crazy after this.
- You would just get so dialed in.
- In the commercials it was
always the coolest thing,
they were like, always like
bopping it on their hip.
(laughing)
- Ah!
- No!
- This stressed me out incredibly.
- [Voiceover] Moon Shoes.
Kid powered anti-gravity shoes!
- Do you wanna hold my hands?
- Not because I need
to, because I want to.
- I think I have to sit down.
Woah!
- This feels unsafe.
- [Girl] Oh god.
- Okay, okay. That's enough.
- [Girl] Okay.
- What?
Is that how you play with
them, you just jump around?
- It's like you're walking on the moon.
- It's just buckets and bands and velcro.
- I wanna jump like they
jump in the commercials.
(laughing)
- You're supposed to jump.
- Neil Armstrong, baby.
- I am not jumping in this thing.
- I think Moon Shoes should come back.
- What I like about 90's toys is there's
just a little bit more danger.
- There's not like a Taylor Swift, 1989
Hit Clips collection, is there?
She pulled all her music off of Spotify,
and put it onto Tiger Hit Clips.